heart music
[Music]
God is good
and all the time
let me try that again God is good
yes God really is Psalm 100 verse 5 for
the Lord is good his Mercy is
Everlasting and his truth endureth to
all generations so we serve a good god
even those who do not serve God they are
benefited by the fact that God is good
because he's making his son to rise on
the
it's too early in the evening
for our war to begin for he may give his
son to rise all the
[Music]
all right I'll take it okay it's the
parent phrase and send it rain on the
read Matthew 5 43 sometime 45 and see
what the Bible says you're making me
make this sin to rise on the even on the
goods and it rain on the just and on the
unjust let me tell you something every
murderer who woke up this morning woke
up because of the goodness of God Amen
and God did not wake him up to kill
somebody else
he woke him up to give him one more
chance to do what
repent
God didn't wake you up today
so you can make more money
he woke you up today to give you another
day to come closer to him
belongs to God
Psalm 36 9 for with thee is the Fountain
of Life understanding clearly I believe
in exercise and vitamin E and whatever
else
but you and I are alive because of God
where's pardon
where oh parking okay
all those visiting Max your right hand
quickly right hand right hand this one
all visitors right hand right hand stand
up
use your feet stand up
ah it's so good to see you
you look nicer than the rest of us come
on the rest of us Say Amen
we're happy with
you of Clayman again
you may be seated
may God bless you in your studies
give your school fees use you to inspire
others and make you a blessing to this
nation
who is from South Africa that's your
writer anyone
South Africa
no not one South African
let me come up a little uh up to the
West Coast Namibia
[Music]
no namibians
no desert lovers okay
let me go up again uh Angola
let me come Eastward Botswana
no one from Botswana
no one from the Kalahari
let's keep going anymore from Zimbabwe
I'll take your show off hands down all
right anyone from let's go all the way
to the east Mozambique
uh God bless you Sister Mozambique okay
all right anyone from Lesotho
no that country is surrounded by South
Africa no anyone from Swaziland the land
of King Swati
the man with two thousand wives no one
from there no one no one no one oh my
let's go a little North anyone from
Malawi
ah God bless you I was in Malawi in
September in a place called Zumba anyone
from what's next to Malawi Zambia
no zambians
you know most of the most of Victoria
Falls is really in Zambia
do you know that but you have done a
remarkable job of marketing
the whole world thinks Victoria Falls is
largely in Zimbabwe
uh if we can only use that skill to
market the gospel
anyone from Tanzania
Uganda
Kenny foreign
from Rwanda
Burundi
Democratic Republic of the Congo
Ethiopia
no Somalia
South Sudan
Sudan no
all zimbabweans all right
well I'm happy to see you wherever
you're from God loves all of us can you
say Amen
he is the god of you know when in
Genesis 14 when Abraham fought a battle
to deliver a lot from captivity
America's the king of Salem brought
forth Bread and Wine and he was the
priest of the most high God Genesis 14
and he blessed him and said Blessed Be
Abram of the most high god possessor of
Heaven and Earth
Psalm 24 verse 1 the Earth is the Lord
and the fullness thereof the world and
they that dwell therein so wherever
you're from This Is My Father's World
our subject for tonight
who is Jesus
you know acts 4 verse 12 says neither is
there salvation in any for there is none
other name unto Heaven given among men
whereby we must be saved there is none
of the name Jesus Christ himself said
with all modesty I am the way the truth
and the life finish the verse
no man cometh unto the father but by me
now as politically incorrect as that may
be in this modern world truth is very
often Politically Incorrect
Jesus says no one
and that no one is no one can come to
the father
but by me amen our subject is who
is Jesus
and why do you need him before I begin
do three little favors for me favor
number one please turn off all your cell
phones some of you have two of them
turn all of them off please
you'll make me very comfortable
and I believe you know how to make a
guest comfortable can you say your mouth
all right while you're turning the cell
phones off favor number two while I'm
speaking pray for me and all I want you
to say is Lord put your words in that
man's mouth and that's based on Jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 which says then the
Lord put forth his hand and touched my
mouth and the Lord said unto me behold I
have put my word in thy mouth I want to
speak God's words not mine and fearful
number three I want you to think
Jeremiah not Jeremiah Isaiah 1 18 come
now let us reason together
Mark chapter 12 reading from verse 28
and one of the scribes came and having
heard them reasoning together he heard
Jesus reasoning
the gospel gospel Bible appeals to
people who reasoned
are you with me man that's why I'm glad
we have so many University students
they should be the first people to
accept truth
because if you reason as you read God's
word you will reason your way right into
God's arms
let's borrow heads and pray
Holy Father in heaven
Lord I ask you from my heart
help me I am an earthened vessel day God
and if you don't help me a lot of dirt
will come out on the message
because that's what I am but if you help
me if you grant me your spirit in
fulfillment of the promise of Jesus
Christ in John 16 13 how be it when he
the spirit of Truth has come he will
guide you into all truth if you activate
that promise in me tonight
then the words I speak will be your
words clean words please God Use Me For
Your Glory not for mine and for the
blessing of your people left the spirit
working through me be the self-same
spirit that touches every listening
heart and that will convict those who
listen to DVDs weeks from now thank you
for the Glorious privilege of preaching
I offer this prayer in Jesus name let
all God's people say amen and amen
Daniel chapter 3 reading from verse 13.
our subject is who is Jesus
Daniel chapter 3 reading from verse 13
you're very familiar with the story of
the Three Hebrew boys in the fire
referred us because they refuse to Bow
along with the rest of the crowd
it was brought to nebuchadnez's
attention that there were three Hebrew
boys who refused to bow
verse 13 of Daniel 3 says then
Nebuchadnezzar in his rage and fury
commanded to bring Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego then they brought these men
before the king Nebuchadnezzar speak and
said unto them is it true
or Shadrach mission on Abednego do we
not serve my gods Lord worship the
golden image which I have made is it
true let me pause on that
a lot of things should be true about us
if the government says to you is it true
that you serve the Adventists follow
Health principles what should you say
yes
it's true
is it true that you have a tithing
system what should we say yes
is it true you believe in marriage
before childbirth what should we say yes
it's true
is it true You observe the seventh
layers of Sabbath what should you say
yes
and so Nebuchadnezzar said Is it true
and you've got to respect him for giving
them a chance to defend themselves is it
true some despots don't ask questions
they just take your head off
is it true Shadrach Mission Abednego do
you not serve my gods nor worship the
golden image which I have made
verse 15 now if you be ready that at
what time you hear the sound of the
Cornet flute Harps sack but sold to me
and all kinds of music he Fall Down and
Worship the image which I have made well
you see it's good if you do that but if
you worship not
he shall be cast
the same out into the midst of a burning
fiery furnace finish verse 6 to 15 for
me
and who is that God
Thou shalt deliver you
out of my hands
and sometimes I entitle this message
meet God
who is that God meet God
our subject for tonight
who is Jesus
because you need to understand the god
of the Old Testament is Jesus Christ
let me say it again
the God who followed the Israelites not
followed LED them in the wilderness was
Christ that's a man who hanged on that
who was hung who was crucified on the
cross the God who destroyed the
Israelite Army in the Red Sea was Christ
amen The God Who said the destroying
Angel and killed every firstborn human
being and every firstborn animal in the
land of Egypt was Christ the same one on
that cross
amen so when Nebuchadnezzar said who is
that God he didn't know it he was
referring to Jesus Christ who is this
God with the power to give you out of
the hands of the most powerful man on
Earth foreign
rulers with power they like to throw
their power around
and so when Jesus stood before Pilate in
John 19 11 the Bible says pilate said to
him uh speak is thou not unto me verses
10 11. nor shall not that I have power
to crucify thee and I have power to
release me
that's intimidation
a lot of Christian leaders use it
a lot of spouses use it
a lot of professors use it amen
intimidation
speak is thou not unto me
nor is thou not that I have power to
crucify thee and I have power to release
thee Jesus answered thou could us have
no power at all against me except it
were given thee from above you and I
need to understand that what happens to
you is not based on who runs the country
it is based on who you serve
when you understand that
you do what is right and you leave the
rest of God are you listening to me
who is Jesus
to understand who Jesus is let's go look
at somebody else
go with me to Luke chapter one
Luke 1 we shall read from verse 10 of
Luke 1.
we're trying to answer the question who
is Jesus
it's already two minutes to seven time
flies very quickly
I am supposed to finish at 7 30 for
those of you visiting for the first time
but I'll go beyond 7 30. and if that
interferes with your life I'll ask the
Lord to bless you
don't worry
when Manchester United goes into
overtime against Chelsea you don't
complain are you with me am I speaking
the truth all right when you sit on the
watch back-to-back episodes of
generations you don't complain about
time
so don't bother me tonight
all right what book did I say
Luke what chapter one reading from verse
10 and the whole multitude of the people
were praying without at the time of the
incense and they appeared unto him an
angel of the Lord standing on the right
side of the older Vincennes and when
Zechariah saw him he was troubled and
fear fell upon him and the angel said
unto him fear not Zacharias for thy
prayer is heard and my wife Elizabeth
shall bear to your son and thou shall
call his name John now the angel Gabriel
came to inform Zacharias that his prayer
that his wife would have a child was
heard and answered
now this is Gabriel speaking to
Zechariah but in first 18 after Gabriel
lays out the lifestyle for this boy from
verse 14 to 16.
17 and verse 18 give Zechariah said
whereby shall I know this
for I am an old man and my wife what
well-strickened in years we're always
bringing human arguments to God
now his argument was biologically valid
it was physiologically valid as we say
the United States he was over the hill
oh you understand
as far as reproducing was concerned and
so was his wife
and so from a secular earth-bound
perspective with no input from Heaven he
had a point
let me tell you something
we have a God who cannot be frustrated
by circumstances
the Rex he couldn't stop him
he part of it
and so Zechariah said whereby shall I
know this seeing I'm an old man and my
wife well strickened in years the angel
answering said unto him verse 19 Luke 1.
I am home
Gabriel
that stand in the presence of God Amen
now
there's something called intimidation
there's also something called
flashing your credentials
are you with me I
I my contribution in the Sabbath school
class
I'm so Gabriel said I am Gabriel just
talk this way just something the devil
is doing his work don't worry I am
Gabriel
that stand in the presence of God
what Gabriel was saying of all the
angels in heaven I occupy a position
closest to God
now Gabriel struck Zacharias dumb
and told him he won't speak until the
child is born
because when the angel crosses to God
brings you a message
which means he got it right from the
mouth of God are you with me and you
doubt it you're in trouble
and so Gabriel said the first time to
behold Thou shalt be dumb and not able
to speak
because that believer's not my words
are you with me it is dangerous to doubt
God's words doubt
is suicidal Behavior
so I go back to verse 19 of Luke 1 I am
Gabriel that stand in the presence of
God
but before Israel Gabriel occupied that
position there was another angel
that occupy the same position
let's go to Ezekiel chapter 28 reading
from verse 12.
Ezekiel 28 waiting from first 12 hour
subject is who is Jesus
we have to find out who Jesus is by
taking a look at Gabriel and Lucifer
Ezekiel 28 verse 12 thou sealants of the
sun this is about Lucifer full of wisdom
and perfect in Beauty
thou has been in Eden the Garden of God
every precious stone was thy covering
the sardius pope has the diamond the
battle of the Onyx The Jasper the
sapphire the emerald the carbuncle and
gold the workmanship of thy cabrison of
thy pipes was prepared in thee in the
days that thou was created verse 14 Thou
Art the anointed chair of that covereth
and I have set these Souls as God
now who's the God speaking in Ezekiel
Jesus
understand me clearly this is Christ now
he wasn't called Christ then
but it is Christ
the god of the Old Testament now
and he says
Thou Art the anointed shut up that
covering
who are the children
that covereth
wrote Exodus 25
when God told Moses to build the ark
which was the first thing to be built
uh when Don is informed him to build a
whole Tabernacle with the most holy the
holy the outer court all the Furnishings
the very first thing God told Moses to
make was the ark that contained The Ten
Commandments
and in describing the architecture of
this piece of furniture
in verse 21 of chapter 25 of Exodus and
thou shalt put the mercy above upon the
ark and here they are that shall put the
testimony that I shall give thee and so
the mercy seat was a covering for the
art now Listen to What God Says in verse
22 and there I will meet with you and I
will commune with thee from above the
mercy read the next few words with me
from what between the cherubim which are
upon the Ark of the testimony in other
words The Mercy Seat had at each end a
terrible you see and the angels they
represented of course the involvement of
the angels in the administration of the
universe are you with me God runs the
universe using angels as his helpers
now the cover of the Ark called The
Mercy Seat was made of gold
the same piece of gold that made the
cover also made the chariable
oh you missed that significance
the same piece of gold that made the
cover also made the two cherubim telling
us that they are closely involved in
God's administration of the universe
they weren't made from a separate piece
of gold then attached they were made
from the same piece of gold that
represents the Throne of God
now in the days of Lucifer apparently
there was only one such angel
listen to Ezekiel 28 verse 14 Thou Art
the anointed share of that covereth and
I have set this all anointed I have
hand-picked you says Christ
I made you and I handpicked you for the
position of being right next to me
closer than any angel
that included Gabriel
follow me closely
I was going to put his words in my mouth
now but we know Lucifer rebelled
verse 15 and Ezekiel 28 that was perfect
in thy ways in the day that thou was
created until iniquity was found in thee
let's find some more biographical
information about Lucifer let's go to
Isaiah 14 we shall read verses 13 and
14. Isaiah 14 reading from verse 13 and
14 our subject is who is Jesus
Isaiah 14.
reading 13 and 14.
well let's read 12 to make a connection
how thou fallen from Heaven oh Lucifer
son of the morning how are thou cut down
to the ground which this weakened the
Nations for thou Hast said in thine
heart I will Ascend into heaven I will
exalt my throne above the heart of God I
will sit also upon the Mount of the
congregation in the sides of the north I
will Ascend above the heights of the
clouds I will be like the most high
that's what Lucifer said somehow
self-exaltation was burst in this angel
now the Bible does not explain how there
are two overriding Mysteries of the
Bible the mystery of iniquity and the
Mystery of godliness
how could sin begin in a perfect
environment that's the mystery of
iniquity and how can a perfect God
arrange a plan to say Sinners that's the
mystery of godliness
verse 15 says yet Thou shalt be brought
down to Hell
to the size of the pig
in other words God says I'm going to
cast you up which he did Revelation 12 7
says and there was war in heaven Michael
and his angels fought against the dragon
and the Dragon for and his angels and
Prevail not neither was their place
found any more in heaven and the Great
Dragon was cast out that Old Devil
called this that old serpent called the
devil and Satan which receiveth the
whole world he was cast out into the
Earth and his angels were cast out with
him so picking information from various
books of the Bible we learned there was
an angel called Lucifer Lucifer made
light bear a lot from the Latin light
pharaoh to bear so you have a fairy that
carries you across the lake are you with
me a carrier of light and his light he
got from Christ because he stood right
next to Christ
he rebelled wanted to fear Christ's
place you can't do that
Christ must have pleaded with him he
wouldn't listen it was a war Christ
threw him out
first drive of Revelation 12 says
therefore rejoshi heavens and he that
dwell in them water the inhabitants of
the earth and of the sea for the devil
has come down unto you when God kicked
him out he chose the Earth
ashes stomping ground
he knows that he has but a short time
now
follow me closely
it is evident from the Bible
that when Lucifer now Satan was cast out
God replaced him
with Gabriel amen
because Gabriel said I am the angel that
stands in the very presence of God now
if you read the Bible carefully Daniel
revelation God always said Gabriel on
the most sensitive missions
so when you wanted to announce the birth
of John the Baptist to prepare the way
for Christ he said Gabriel
when he wanted to announce to a young
girl she would be the mother of God he
said Gabriel are you with me when he
wanted to explain to Daniel the
mysteries of the vision Daniel had seen
in Daniel 7 he said Gabriel amen tells
you clearly that Gabriel has an exalted
position and Gabriel himself said in
Daniel 10 21 but I will show them to
thee the what is noted in the scripture
of Truth and there's none that holdeth
with me in these things but Michael your
prince Gabriel says the only one that
can hang with me in understanding these
things this is Michael
who is God Christ amen
so Gabriel gives us information of the
position he occupies
now some angels are more powerful than
others
please understand that clearly let me
say it again some angels have more power
than others let me reverse that some
demons have more power than others to be
demonic
listen listen to me
there are some demons that are so
powerful that Satan assigns them
to uh people whom he sees are too close
to Christ
are you in so if there's a preacher
who's really powerful the devil tells
demon you will take your win I want to
end your powerful demon
let me explain what I mean Luke 11 24-26
when the unclean spirit is gone out of a
man he walketh through Dry places he can
rest
what's the unclean Spirit a demon and
finding none he's safe I will return
unto my house from whence I came
and when he cometh he's fine with his
swept and garnished then goes here and
taketh to him seven other Spirits more
wicked than himself
are you with me
the Bible says some demons are more
wicked than other demons now why is that
because those demons at one point who
are they
they were Holy Angels
and angels have different degrees of
power and authority now what that tells
us if you reasoning with me when those
angels were cast out
they lost their position what did they
not lose
power
hear me carefully
that applies to Satan
Satan lost
his position
but he left heaven
with all his power now you must
understand that to understand who Jesus
is
are you with me I'm not talking about
Satan because I love him no but I want
you to see white is whitest when it's up
against black am I right
huh to understand how tall a man is put
him next to the short man
are you following me
you don't put Shaquille O'Neal next to
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar to figure out who is
tall no you put Kareem on Shaquille next
to me then you realize this guy is tall
so now to understand Jesus
I'm trying to talk about Satan then I'll
bring you to I'll bring in Jesus at the
right time
Satan was cast out lost his position but
he left heaven with all his
not
in Daniel 10
in Daniel 9 Daniel was fasting three
weeks because he has studied the
Prophecies of Jeremiah and he realized
that the time is coming when the
Israelites must do one
go back to Jerusalem
because God said you'll be into activity
70 years
a decade or 70 years all right So Daniel
now starts to pray he's fasting three
weeks
and he doesn't eat he doesn't drink
doesn't even shower
he's fasting now God sends Gabriel
to answer Daniel's prayer
are you with me now go over to Daniel 10
we're going to read from verse 12. our
subject is who is Jesus it is 7 15.
this should be a two-part message
and I may not see you again so I have to
give everything tonight
do you have Daniel 10 from verse 12
then said he unto me meaning Daniel is
talking about the experience
fear not Daniel
for from the first day that thou they
said thine heart to understand and to
chasten thyself before thy God thy words
were heard
when did God hear Daniel's prayer
how long did Daniel pray three weeks
are you praying to God you haven't
gotten the answer
keep praying
this may explain why he has an answer
it's just maybe one reason
he said thy words were and I am come for
Thy word verse 13 says but the prince of
the world Kingdom of Persia keep reading
withstood me how long
one and 20 days
now wait a minute
who is speaking
Gabriel what is Gabriel's position
the highest angel in heaven
now who can withstand the highest angel
in heaven for even one second
who is this Prince of the kingdom of
Persia that held up the highest angel in
heaven for 21 days
now this is where reasoning is essential
there's almost no court case that's one
an absolute foof proof
they're argued on the basis of what
evidence
the evidence tends to pump the point in
the direction that you're following
that's being honest are you following it
now
Gabriel said this person referred to as
the prince of the kingdom of Persia with
certainly one in 20 days now let's take
a look at what happens to human beings
when they see an angel
then we can determine is the Springs of
the kingdom of Persia an angel a human
being or some other being
in Numbers 22 31
bailam is on a donkey going on a mission
that he should not be going on
and the donkey stops you know the story
and Balaam starts to talk to the donkey
the donkey talks back and their lamb is
not even aware the donkey's talking back
that's how people lose their minds when
they get mad
are you following me anger interferes
with comprehension
yeah now the Bible says in verse 31 of
Numbers 22 then the Lord opened the eyes
of Balaam and he saw the angel of the
Lord standing in his way and his sword
drawn in his hand and he bowed on his
head finish the verse and fell flat on
his face
that's the reaction of a human being
when he sees an angel
let us go to Matthew chapter 28 reading
from verse 1 move quickly please because
time is flying even more quickly than
you are doing your search of the Bible
Matthew 28 reading from verse 1 the
Bible says in the end of the Sabbath as
it began to Dawn toward the first day of
the week Came Mary Magdalene and the
other Mary to see the Sepulcher and
behold there was an earthquake
for the angel of the Lord descended from
heaven and came come back the throne
from the door and sat upon him his
countenance was like lightning and his
remote white to snow and for fear of him
the keepers did what
and became as well
who were the people's soldiers
now these are hardened men accustomed to
killing people
when they saw one Angel they fell in a
dead fate go to Luke chapter 2. reading
from verse 8 and they were in the same
country shepherds abiding in the fields
keeping watch over the floor by night
and Lord the angel of the Lord Came Upon
them and the glory of the Lord Shone
round about them and there was so afraid
and the angel said unto them fear not
now who are these Shepherds out at night
remember remember David killed the bear
Come on talk to me remember if they
killed a lion
remember Samson killed a lion remember
he caught 300 foxes there were bears and
like there were wild animals in the land
of Christ where by then
are you with me
so these men out at night were tough men
they were willing to take on lions
hyenas foxes Bears to defend the Sheep
these are the men that when they saw an
angel their knees began to knock
and the angel had to say it's okay
what am I saying from Genesis of
Revelation whenever a human being sees
an angel the human being is terrified
when we go back to Daniel chapter 10
verse 13 but the prince of the kingdom
of Persia with stood me one and twenty
days it could not have been the human
King
because there's no precedent in the
Bible of a human being resisting the
weakest angel
and we're talking about the most
powerful angel
now let me show you how intense the
opposition was to Gabriel
verse 13 Daniel 10.
but the prince of the kingdom of Persia
withstood me one in 20 days now read
with if you have that passage but low
Michael amen one of the chief princes
did what
came to help me
no do you understand why I was
emphasizing the power of Gabriel and
Satan
Gabriel is the highest angel in heaven
now
but it is obvious from Daniel 10 12 and
13.
he does not have enough power
to overcome Satan
no I am not speaking bad about Gabriel
I look forward to seeing Gabriel in the
Kingdom
but listen to me carefully
Gabriel
does not have the power of himself to
overcome Satan
here's how the power structure was in
heaven before Lucifer was cast out it
was God the Father God the son God the
Holy Ghost this is the organizational
floor chart father son Holy Ghost the
all equal and I'll show you that before
this series ends right under them was
Lucifer
argue with me amen right under them was
between Lucifer and God there was there
was some other level of authority
when you bypass Lucifer where did you go
straight to God let me say it again you
need to get this
here's god father son Holy Ghost highest
level of power the second highest was
Lucifer
he was thrown out
the second highest level now is Gabriel
now he occupies that position
but the power Lucifer had
Gabriel did not get he got the same
position but not the same power
but he is still the second highest under
God
now what I'm saying is the angel in
heaven that's the greatest power next to
God
in heaven
cannot stand against Satan
what that means follow me closely
that levels of Power are this way
God
who's next Satan
then Gabriel
listen to me the second greatest power
in the universe is the power of the
devil
you need to know who you're up against
some people think they can go study
karate to deal with the Devil
the only Power greater than Satan's
power is God
are you with me now so Gabriel said the
prince of the kingdom of Persia must
have been Satan
will stood me
one of 20 days but Lord Michael
one of the chief princes nah came to
help me amen now if Gabriel needed help
with Satan
[Music]
what about me what about you with all
respect
Gabriel confesses with no Pride Michael
one of the the prince means the ruler
Chief princess could refer to father son
Holy Ghost so one of them came meaning
Christ Michael
to help me
in my struggle with whom
see
now
who is Jesus
the only Power
that can help you with safety the only
Power you see if Jesus doesn't help you
the only hope you have with the Devil is
a draw
come on you're sleeping with your eyes
open we only hope you and I have a draw
but no one gets into heaven on the basis
of a draw
they must be a victory
and Gabriel said I needed help
Michael came
and help me amen Michael means who's
like God
Michael came to help me
and if Gabriel needed help
with the highest power on the god which
is Satan you and I need the help now
sync with me again
here is God next greatest power in the
universe of sacred then Gabriel
no
to defeat Satan if he's the second
greatest power
you've got to be one
God say don't be afraid to say it you've
got to be gone are you with me
amen you've got to be God
because the greatest problem right under
God is Satan which means the only Power
that can defeat him is God so that Jesus
then finish it for me
amen
let's finish it Jesus then must be
I didn't say he's the father but he's
divine he is as much God as the father
is God because only God can deal with
Satan
let me tell you something when you give
your life to Jesus you give your life to
the only Power that can control the
enemy of your soul and that is Jesus
Christ
that's why I said and try to destroy him
Jesus came down this same power Christ
came down lived as a human being
he was God and man tremendous mystery he
was fully godfully Man by the way he
understands everything you and I go
through no matter what your problem is
said Jesus you understand you may not
understand how he understands but he
understands
he lived resisted every Temptation Of
The Devil yes
yes then he died
you know there's some good people I
admire
hmm
they have admirable teachings
I admire some of the teachings of Buddha
are you with me
have some good teachings I admire them
he died
Confucius had some good teachings
hard work you know decency good manners
he had those teachings Millions followed
him he died
I admire some things about Muhammad
prayer five times a day give Harms
they don't die worship one God some
things you should admire he died
Jesus came along just as human as
Muhammad there are some things he said
everything he said I admire he died
Buddha died still dead
all right are you with me huh
Confucius came along he died still dead
Muhammad came along he died still dead
Jesus came along he died and he rose
and so one I admire Confucius I worship
Jesus while I admire Buddha I worship
Jesus why admire Muhammad I worship
Jesus because Jesus died and came back
if Muhammad could have come back he
would have come back
but he does not have power over death
if Buddha could have come back he would
have come back
he has no power over death that has
power over him but death is the greatest
enemy
that's why death says The Last Enemy
that shall be destroyed now Jesus
submitted himself to death
there are two things you know you it's
the one thing about being killed nothing
about giving up your life
two different things
someone's shooting at you you run you
get shot in the head you die there's
nothing heroic about that you are
running
but to stand up in front of a rifle and
say I am dying for what I believe kill
me now that's another story you weren't
killed you gave up your life
thus lay down his life
he went into the territory of the
greatest enemy you see the Bible says
the devil it has the power of death
Hebrews 2 14.
for as much then as the children of
partakers of Flesh and Blood he also
himself likewise took part of the same
that through death he might destroy him
that had the power of death that is the
devil
the devil has the power of death death
is the worst enemy God has to deal with
Satan went into the reign of death went
into the realm of death into the realm
of the power of Satan
to demonstrate his power over Satan and
on the third day Jesus came back from
death but let me tell you something else
the Bible says the father raised him it
says there are several places but you
need to understand what that means
the father did not actually raise Christ
the father had told Christ who went to
get up
amen John 10 16 17 other sheep I have
which a lot of this Falls them also I
must bring in this shall hear my voice
and they shall be once more than one
Shepherd therefore of the father loved
me because I laid on my life that I
might take it again no man taketh it
from me I laid down of myself I have
power to lay down who can finish the
verse and I have power to do all take it
up again this commandment of I received
of my father the father said son I will
tell you
went to get up
but the power to get up
is it you are you with me now here's why
weak if
we would be serving a God who needed
help
ah you're not with me you know we would
be serving a God who needed help but
Jesus needs no help the Bible says when
he had by himself purged our sins are
you with me the Bible says there's
salvation in Christ Christ raised
himself in his demonstration of his
power over death
he raised himself
and Only God can raise himself
having died in humanity he raised
himself in his divinity why
demonstrating that the greatest
expression of power Satan has is death
and Jesus faced it and conquered it
by the way
that's the same power Christ uses in
your life
Ephesians 1 19 20 and what is the
exceeding greatness of his power to
Assad who believe according to the
working of his mighty power which he
wrought in Christ when he raised him
from the dead the power that raised
Christ from the dead the power that
Jesus used to reverse death is the same
power he uses to break your own
addiction to drugs thank you
and to six
until liquor
and your addiction to disobedience
come on
the worst form of disability of
addiction is addiction to Disobedience
you show something from the Bible as
clear as dead and people will not do it
addicted to disobedience
Jesus says I have the power over death
amen I went into it
came back I stayed three days so you can
be convinced I was dead you know in
Revelation chapter 1 verse 18 says I'm
he that liveth and was dead amen what
Jesus says and I'm alive forever more
who is Jesus he is God who is Jesus the
only one who can help you with Satan who
is Jesus the one who came to help
Gabriel who is Jesus the only Power Of
Satan cannot overcome
when you are in Christ
the devil can bother you he can't
overcome you he bothered Christ
he bothered Abraham he bothered the boy
he always has his work but bothering is
not the same thing as conquering
my brothers and sisters
who is Jesus Jesus is the only Power in
the universe that can help you in your
battle with sin
because the power of sin is the power of
Satan which is the second greatest power
in the universe
and the only Power that can conquer that
is the power of God who have called us
out of Darkness
into His Marvelous Light who is leading
your life
is it Christ
or see
Gabriel needed the help of Christ who
are you
think because you have a degree you have
a match for Satan
because you're related to the president
your match for Satan
and because you can trace your descent
from romula your match was Satan no no
no no no no
you better trace your descent to Christ
and I
trace my
because he is the only hope and so
Nebuchadnezzar said
who is that God
that shall deliver you
out of my heart
the most powerful hands on Earth you see
Nebuchadnezzar competed with the most
powerful hands in the universe God
Christ and Christ had to surely because
he was and the beginning said did not be
cast three men bound Into the Fire amen
but Lord I see four men loose
and this form of the fourth is like the
son of God
he said we put three but I see four
let me tell you something when you are
with Christ you are never one
you're always too and three because
Christ comes with angels
who's running your life
who
is either Christ
or Satan this is me the gospel is simple
the Bible is sin might be nine percent
of it I told you before Daniel
Revelation they have some challenging
areas but those could have understood if
we study seriously the Bible is
overwhelmingly simple to those who in
their hearts and souls want to know
what's right who directs your life in
the Garden of Eden God said if you eat
you die the devil said if you eat you
live
which they said who tells you the way to
be blessed is to sin
that's what he's saying
he packages sin so beautifully
and if you're a good Advertiser you know
it's not so much the quality of your
product it's the way you present it
so people eat snails but it is packaged
as escargot are you following me I'm
there eating snails but don't call it
snails
put it on expensive plate
and he's a silver fork and it does it
it's no longer
this is a mushroom
are you following me you don't sell
cigarettes in a black and white box
you such a nice box nicely decide and
then you probably you make a cigarette
case out of gold and you carry it in a
super pocket
how do you drink
we made goblet you just can't hold a
glass like this no you hold it between
I'm just looking around with me then you
take a sip and you roll it around in
your mouth you're rolling around death
in your mouth you're rolling around and
then you'll be that's how you drink that
the devil packages these things
that's what he told Adam and Eve for God
to know that in the days they're off
then your eyes shall be open and you
shall be a scotch knowing good and evil
if you sin you'll be God
and we believe that yes
listen to me there are two voices
What God Says what saves himself you
choose yes amen if Adam had chosen what
God Said
I wouldn't be here sweating
I'd be you know relaxing on table
mountainous
I'll be visiting Pluto
I've been here
he said to Adam Genesis 3 verse 17.
hello
to said because thou has hearkened unto
the voice of them
listen to me when you do what you do
whose voice is directing you
make a commitment before you leave this
thing
I want Christ
as my Lord
you know what the Lord means you know
what savior means
a deliverer from sin that's savior amen
you know what the Lord is someone who
tells me how to live ah you missed it
you see most of us we want Christ as
Savior
Lord I'm in quicksand get me out
I have this kill me
my boyfriend beats me up when my
girlfriend beats me of stopper
but when the Lord does it then we say
thank you Jesus now leave me alone let
me live my life we don't want him as
Lord yes are you following me we want
him a savior not Lord
but he's either both or he's not
amen
yes my question to you is I know you
want him a savior no more argument no
controversy no fight is he Lord
do you live your life based on what he
says
I want you to keep coming every night
I'm here what exams you have
God will shorten your mind God will put
to tell the Professor set the exam only
on the material you could study
amen as a reward for your presence in
this meeting yes but God will send an
angel next to you and said Angel tell
her what
answer the check check bhxc check a for
Adventist check
God knows how to come through come every
night
because God will give you messages to
you you need an ID to be reminded myself
but for tonight I want you to say
I want Christ as Lord
to tell me what to do yes how many of
you will say Jesus come to me as Lord
direct my life tell me how to live if
you will say that raise this right hand
come on raise it tell me how to live as
Lord stand up
because if Jesus doesn't lead your life
Satan is leading your life there isn't
of her choice
you know Matthew not Matthew
Ezekiel 33 11. listen to the words of
God you can hear his heart break in
as I live save the Lord
I have no pleasure in the death of the
wicked
but that the wicked turns on his ways
yes yes attorney
from your evil ways for why will he die
or House of Israel why
why persist in a life that takes you on
a marble path to death
Deuteronomy 5 29 here God begging again
oh that's it was such a heart of them
that it was funny
I keep all my Commandments forward oh
that they have a heart
all they give me are worse
I love Jesus I love Jesus praise the
Lord
but the heart
is far from me
you and I are up against Apollo that can
only be controlled by the power of God
in the Life of Christ amen if Gabriel
needed help
you and I need it critically yes you've
said to say I want Christ as Lord
Christ will direct you in every area of
your life
to do differently is to hurt yourself
now
and in the Life to Come amen
that's about eyes closed
loving father in Heaven if I have
preached badly forgive me dear God
sometimes I get too excited
you take what I've done this meager
effort father
and apply to everyone who listened
but I try to show that the greatest
threat to us is the power of Satan
not even Gabriel could withstand him
and my favorite author says bear in mind
it is none but God that can hold an
argument with sin
my favorite author also says the prince
of the power of evil can only be held in
check by the power of God
and so I pray that God you give us
Divine common sense
to stand on the side of Christ who
conquered Satan death hell sin and Grave
and who offers to us that same
conquering power to work in our lives
while every head is bowed every eye is
closed I'm asking a very strange
question
the church I don't have it
or they grew up in a so-called Christian
home but they have never consciously
willfully of their own free will give
them their lives to Christ
if you have never consciously given your
life to Christ by saying Lord I give you
my life lead me if you've never
consciously done that you've just been
all working on automatic pilot because
you grew up in a Christian environment
and tonight you want to say Jesus I
consciously individually personally give
my life to you if there's such a person
I want you to raise your right hand
you've never consciously given your life
to Christ
you want to do it tonight
raise your right hand
you've never done it my brother I see
your hand
come I'm going to pray for you very
special to come is there any other hat
come I come come come Don't Be Afraid
come is that a hand come I'm very
serious you have never consciously said
Lord I give you my life
it's not something that happens
automatically you must consciously give
your life to Christ come just stand
right here let me pray for you
can I have some cards to give to God's
people please so I can take those cards
and pray for them you have never
consciously said Lord I give you my life
do it tonight and you want to do it come
it takes a second like that for Jesus
Christ to work a miracle in the heart
amen anyone else I have never
consciously of my own free will with no
inference from anyone given my life to
Christ I want to do that now this
conquering Christ this power alone that
can control Satan I want you to come and
make that commitment to Christ we will
pray you will leave this place as a
child of God Amen they don't have that
child of God because you go to church
you're a child of God because you give
your life to him
and you tell him to direct it anyone
else
all the Pharisees were church members
they were not children of God and so
Jesus name
Satan has a lot of people in church
don't be wonderful
anyone else
you have never consciously
of your own free will say Jesus
take my life and lead me to come
I pray we go home anyone else
don't ask what will people say
let them say what they want
you ask a question what will Jesus say
if I don't do it
and who will benefit if I don't it won't
be God if he said come
and say I consciously
of my own free will
give my life to The God Who alone can
conquer Satan my brother God bless you
come someone else
if I pray
a quarter of seven or eight I know that
God can stretch down don't worry
I'll ask him to bless your studies and
he will if you study hard he'll do the
rest God bless you my brother come
if this person a card
then I'll pray we go come back tomorrow
and the rest of you who've already given
the life to Christ this is not a
spectator sport you should be praying
because there are people struggling
we'll look to see who can pray because
Satan is doing his work
let's outwork him
anyone else
you came to church just because your
parents brought you now you're in the
beginning
you're old enough to decide I am giving
my life you only give you 20 you can be
12 to it Christ was 12 he knew what his
business was
anyone else
just come
I pray and we go home
I give you 60 seconds God bless my young
brother
the younger you come the better it is
when you come to Christ at 1670 he has
so much to dig out of you
when you come at 12 he has very little
to change
the sooner the better
the sooner the better and Satan knows
that that's why he gets the young people
in all kinds of music all Dance all
sorts of stuff he gets them because once
he has them he knows he has them for
Life most of the time but come to Christ
early let Christ have you for life
30 seconds
I consciously
from my own heart which has been touched
give my life
to Christ as Savior and Lord 15 seconds
then we pray
let me tell you how happy my heart is to
see
the seal
Edge bound
if you're convicted while I'm praying
come join the prayer you will not
disturb the prayer loving father in
Heaven
and now come back to finish the prayer
God
I can only speak for you I cannot
convict the heart
you can through your spirit
I'm asking you now very deliberately
personally and publicly
you've said in second Peter 3 9. the
Lord is not slack concerning his
promises some mental Slackers but as we
long suffering to us not willing that
any of these who came forward should
perish
but that all of them should come to
eternal life
father if you meant it when you wrote it
Please Stand by Your Word
and give the spirit to these men women
boys and girls who came that that Spirit
of Christ May strengthen them may
support them may sustain them in their
battle against him
mark them as yours by giving them your
spirit their God I pray and for those
who are struggling their father
with this decision to consciously give
the life to you give them the rest until
they make the most intelligent decision
a man or woman can make and that is to
surrender to Christ give them no rest
now father take us home safely let the
powerful angels escort us to all our
homes defend us from the attacks of the
enemy let the words we've heard remain
on our minds and not be plucked Away by
idle conversation
bring us back tomorrow I pray please
in Jesus powerful name that all God's
people say amen and amen God bless you
God bless you do we have all the cards
of all your names God bless you from my
heart
come back tomorrow God bless all of you
I love you come back tomorrow bring
someone with you to listen to God's
saving word
[Music]
yeah
peace
[Music]
you wish